- [Narrator] Hi this is
Kim from Khan Academy.
Today we're learning
more about the landmark
Supreme Court case Dred
Scott versus Sandford.
Decided in 1857, the ruling
in the Dred Scott case
inflamed sectional tensions over slavery,
which had been growing ever more heated
over the course of the 1850s.
Originally a case about whether
one man ought to be free,
Dred Scott versus Sandford
transformed into a case
about African-American citizenship
and the future of the
institution of slavery itself.
To learn more, I sought
out help of two experts.
Christopher Bracey is a Professor of Law
at the George Washington
University School of Law.
He's an expert in US race
relations, individual rights
and criminal procedure.
Timothy Huebner is the Irma O. Sternberg
Professor of History at Rhodes College
and the author of Liberty
and Union: The Civil War Era
and American Constitutionalism.
Professor Bracey can you
take us through a little bit,
just who was Dred Scott and
why did he bring this case?
- [Christopher] So Dred
Scott was born around 1800
and was the slave of Peter
and Elizabeth Taylor Blow.
In 1818, Peter Blow
decides to move his family
and Dred Scott to Alabama
where he'd bought a cotton plantation.
That didn't go so well,
so he sells the plantation
and moves the family
and Dred to St. Louis, Missouri,
where he'd purchased a
boarding house called
The Jefferson Hotel.
- [Timothy] And that
period really was a period
during which the nation was arguing over
the status of slaves and
the rights of slaveholders
and the future of slavery
in new western territories.
And this issue came up
in a very significant way
and a very controversial
way in the question
of the future of slavery in the territory
and ultimately the state of Missouri.
After two years of arguing over this,
finally in 1820 and 1821,
a sort of compromise
was set out by members of Congress.
North of the southern border of Missouri,
with the exception of
the state of Missouri,
slavery would be banned.
- [Christopher] In 1830,
Elizabeth Taylor Blow dies
and Peter himself dies two years later.
But before he does, he
makes an arrangement to sell
Dred to an Army physician
by the name of Dr. Emerson.
Dr. Emerson is an Army
physician, so he's gonna be
stationed in a lot of different places,
not just in the slave state of Missouri.
In fact, it turns out that
Dr. Emerson's first posting
with Dred takes him to Fort Armstrong,
which is located in Rock Island, Illinois
and Illinois is of course a free state.
Under both federal law and Missouri law
as understood at the
time, Dred would have lost
his slave status and become a free man
as soon as he stepped
foot onto free territory.
This was known as the Extra-territorial
Emancipation Doctrine.
- [Timothy] It was perfectly
legal and perfectly possible
for a slave sojourner, a
slave who had been taken
into a free state or free territory,
to file suit for his freedom.
- [Christopher] Dr. Emerson marries
Eliza Irene Sandford of St. Louis.
Dr. Emerson eventually
dies in 1843 and he leaves
the entire estate, including
the Scotts, to Mrs. Emerson.
Mrs. Emerson decides she
would like to hire Dred out
to make some money for herself.
Rather than be hired out,
Dred offers to purchase
his own freedom, and the
freedom of his entire family.
But Mrs. Emerson refuses
to allow Dred to buy out
the freedom of his family.
So Dred Scott files a civil lawsuit,
what was called a Freedom Suit back then,
in the Missouri State court.
And his claim was that
Mrs. Emerson was falsely
imprisoning him and his family.
- [Timothy] And he was able
to do this with the help
of the sons of his formers owners.
- [Christopher] The lawyer
is being paid by the children
of Peter and Elizabeth Taylor Blow,
- [Narrator] Wow.
Dred Scott's first master.
In the meantime you
have a new development,
Mrs. Emerson has remarried
to Republican congressman Calvin
Chaffee, from Massachusetts
and he can't be a slave owner and still be
a Republican congressman
from Massachusetts.
So Mrs. Emerson transfers
title of the Scotts
to her brother John
Sandford who is a resident
of New York, with business
ties in St. Louis.
- [Timothy] Now it was
eligible for the case
to go into Federal Court
in that it involved people
who lived in two different states.
- [Christopher] So now
you might be thinking,
"Well, filing a lawsuit
against your purported master,
that's pretty brave stuff."
But as it turns out freedoms
suits of this nature
were not that uncommon,
particularly in border states
where the slavery question
was hotly disputed.
Indeed there were some 300
or so of these freedom suits
that were filed in
Missouri during the period
in which Dred Scott filed his case.
Many people viewed the Missouri
Compromise as not so much
of a compromise but as
something that was forced
upon the slave states.
And then you've got
the Kansas-Nebraska Act
which gave similar autonomy
to those areas to decide
the slavery question and
whether or not it would be
introduced into those territories.
- [Narrator] Interesting,
so people in the North
who opposed slavery or at the very least
didn't want slavery to expand,
would have been looking
in the 1850s and saying,
"Hey I thought we already
decided this, there wouldn't
be slavery north of this line
and now you're saying
maybe Kansas and Nebraska
could be slave states."
- [Timothy] Right and
that was a huge issue
in national politics because
northerners are starting
to grow very suspicious of
southerners on the slavery issue.
They're starting to
speak of what they called
the slave power,
that southern slaveholders
held all of this power
in Washington and that
they were running the show.
And that this 1854 act
had made it possible
for slavery to potentially
expand into an area
where previously it had been banned.
- [Christopher] And you
really do get this escalation
of tension and the
Fugitive Slave Act of 1850
which basically forced
requirements upon free states
to ensure the longevity
of the slave states
by requiring them to
undertake certain behaviors
and the return of fugitive
slaves only escalated
the tension and concern
about the status of slavery
in American life.
- [Narrator] Alright so we're
in this incredibly tense time
of the 1850s with the slavery
question yet unanswered
and Dred Scott and his case
gets to the Supreme Court.
So how does the Supreme
Court rule on this?
- [Christopher] In a seven to two ruling,
the Supreme Court held that
Dred Scott was not a citizen
of the United States, and so therefore
he could not bring his freedom
suit before federal court,
which is really a jurisdictional question.
But then the Court also
goes on to invalidate
the Missouri Compromise, despite finding
that it lacked jurisdiction
to hear the case.
- [Timothy] What happens
when the case is being argued
is that one of the
arguments that's introduced
is this idea that when
Scott had been taken
into free territory, he
wasn't necessarily free
because the Missouri Compromise
was unconstitutional.
And so what the Court
ends up doing is not only
ruling on the status of Scott, but also on
the status of slavery in
these federal territories
in the west and the extent
of the powers of Congress
over slavery in the west.
- [Narrator] Interesting so
Chief Justice Roger Taney
is then leading the Supreme
Court and he, I guess,
leads the reasoning about this case.
So what were some of the arguments that he
eventually accepted and
made in his decision?
- [Timothy] Chief Justice Taney's
a very interesting figure.
He had been on the court for many years.
He, in his early years, had
been moderately anti-slavery,
had freed most of his
own slaves, and had made
anti-slavery statements.
But by 1857 Taney
reflected the larger change
that had taken place
within his political party,
Taney was a Democrat.
And the Democratic party
had become more Southern
dominated and more pro-slavery.
And Taney then, by
1857, really is a symbol
of pro-slavery Southern thought.
- [Christopher] Justice Taney's opinion
is somewhat notorious.
He makes a series of arguments and
one is legal, the others are
really not legal arguments
as I'll explain.
What he starts out by
saying is that just because
you're a citizen of a state,
that does not make you
a citizen of the United States.
He says basically the federal government
has exclusive authority
to decide who is a citizen
of the United States.
Then he makes a second
argument and he says
even if Dred Scott were a
citizen of the state of Missouri
he would not be a citizen
of the United States
because he's black.
And what he meant by that
is that the word citizen
as used in the Constitution
and the Declaration of
Independence categorically excluded
members of the Negro race.
- [Narrator] This is fascinating
because it seems to me
like Justice Taney may have
been ignoring a long history
of free people of color
in the United States
who had voting rights,
who had property rights.
- [Timothy] He was and that
was part of the criticism
of the majority opinion that comes in,
especially the dissent written
by Justice Benjamin Curtis.
Curtis had the lengthier
of the two dissents
and the more thorough legal argument
because, as you point
out, that in five states
at the time of the founding,
that African-Americans
did exercise the right to vote
that was a sign or some
sort of an indication
of their status as citizens.
And so the argument made
by Justice Curtis then,
is that Taney's reading of
history was that the founders
had not intended for
African-Americans to be part of
the people or the citizens
that were referred to
in the text of the US Constitution.
- [Christopher] What
Justice Taney has done here
has basically created a
blind spot for himself
and he goes on to point out
that this is not his belief,
this belief in Negro inferiority,
but he said that it was
a fixed and universal belief
within the civilized portion
of the white race, he said
it was an axiom, a truth.
But what's interesting
is that he says this
without a citation.
He says that these aren't his
views, these are the views
of the framers, the
great men who were high
in literary accomplishment,
high in their sense of honor.
He said that they perfectly
understood the language
that they used, and how it
would be understood by others.
And there's this great
quote in the opinion
where he says that they,
the framers, knew that
it would not in any part
of the civilized world
be supposed to embrace the Negro race,
which by common consent had been excluded
from civilized governments
and the family of nations
and doomed to slavery.
What Justice Taney has done here,
is he's attempted to rewrite history.
- [Narrator] So how the
American people respond to the
Dred Scott decision at large?
Where they generally
for it, or aghast by it?
- [Timothy] Well as you might expect,
things were split exactly down the middle.
What we see in the South
is white Southerners
believe that the ruling is a vindication
of what they had been arguing.
Southerners had been
arguing for many years
going back to John C.
Calhoun, that Southerners
and that Southern slave
holders had a bundle of rights.
And they argued that they
had the right to own slaves
as property in the southern states.
They argued that they
had a right to recapture
fugitive slaves who escaped into the north
and they also argued that they had a right
to take slaves into the west.
And so Southerners then
feel that the Court
and the US Constitution are on their side.
You see a lot of folks in
the north who are hostile
to what the Court has done,
because once again they
see it as further evidence that the Court
is dominated by the Democratic
party, by the slave power.
And many of these folks
then are going to be
members of a new party,
and that was of course
the Republican Party.
- [Christopher] I think the
abolitionists were furious
and I think Frederick
Douglas' statement calling it
a brazen misstatement of facts of history,
a scandalous and devilish
perversion of the Constitution
resonated and even future
Presidential candidate
Abraham Lincoln, that same
summer that the case was decided,
went out and denounced it publicly.
- [Narrator] So Lincoln of
course wins the election
of November 1860 which becomes
a precipitating event of the Civil War.
Do you see the Dred Scott
decision as being a really
important cause of the Civil War?
- [Timothy] Yeah so these things
are all linked, absolutely.
Think about the ruling by
Taney in Dred Scott ruling that
slave-holders rights are absolute.
Taney rules African-Americans
have no rights,
slaveholders have total rights.
This makes it possible for Lincoln to rise
as a political leader in the north because
he has something that he
can strongly criticize.
Lincoln basically makes the
argument that the founders
had hoped for slavery
to disappear ultimately.
And Taney's making exactly
the opposite argument.
So the interesting thing
is, if you think about
how this story ends, it
ends in March of 1861
when Abraham Lincoln is
sworn-in as the 16th President.
And who swears him in?
Of course Roger B. Taney.
So between the time
when Lincoln was elected
in November of 1860 and
the time when he takes that
oath of office in March of 1861,
seven Southern slave-holding states,
those are the states that
leave the Federal Union first.
Four other states of
course will join them,
but not until after the Civil
War has already started.
- [Narrator] So there's
no Compromise of 1860,
instead what we get is a
four-year long Civil War
where more than 620,000
Americans are killed.
And at the end of that war,
the North, the United States
is victorious and slavery
in the 13th Amendment
is abolished forever.
How does the end of the
Civil War relate back
to the Dred Scott case?
- [Timothy] The 13th
Amendment ends slavery,
the 14th Amendment has
to undermine or overturn
the other part of the
Supreme Court's ruling
which was this issue
of the rights of those
who previously had been held as slaves.
And the 14th Amendment
is going to do that work
by stating that all who
were born in this country,
by virtue of their birth here are citizens
and that they have rights
that will be protected
by the Federal government.
And if you think about
it, what has changed,
what has shifted, is the whole
national discourse of rights,
from the emphasis on the
rights of slaveholders
that we see in 1857, to
an emphasis on the rights
of those who previously
had been held as slaves.
And arguably then what we
see during the Civil War
and Reconstruction is the
advent of a new discourse
focusing on human rights.
And that I would argue is
profoundly significant.
- [Narrator] So what happened
to Dred Scott after this?
Did he and his wife live to see the end
of the Civil War and the end of slavery?
- [Christopher] Unfortunately
Dred Scott did not.
The Supreme Court renders
its decision in 1857
but he dies, unfortunately in 1858.
His wife Harriet though,
lives on to about 1876.
So she did live to see
the end of the Civil War
and the end of slavery.
The Dred Scott case
made clear, at the time,
that the struggle for
citizenship and of course
the later struggle for civil rights,
is about the desire to be
treated with equal dignity,
to be viewed as possessing equal humanity.
And what is perhaps most moving, I think,
about the Dred Scott case
is the dignity with which
the Scotts carried themselves
throughout the entire ordeal,
despite the Court's best
efforts to deprive them
of that dignity.
It was ultimately Dred and
Harriet who gained the respect
of the nation.
And it was the inhumanity of the Court
and the institution of
slavery that was laid bare
for all to see.
- [Narrator] So we've learned
that the ruling in Dred Scott
helped bring about the Civil
War by further dividing
the North and South over
the issue of slavery.
Opposition to the case's outcome propelled
Abraham Lincoln to the
national political stage
and opposition to Abraham
Lincoln propelled slave states
to secede after his election as President.
But the Dred Scott case was
also about the lives and fates
of one man and his family.
Although Dred didn't survive
to see the end of slavery
and the passage of the 14th Amendment
granting equal citizenship
to African-Americans,
his family lived to see the rewards
of the struggle he began.
To learn more about the Dred Scott case,
visit the National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution
and Khan Academy's
resources on US history.